>> Shannon: THERE IS SO MUCH
UNCERTAINTY RIGHT NOW.
PLENTY OF MISINFORMATION OUT
THERE.
WE ARE TAKING YOUR QUESTIONS TO
THE EXPERTS.
WE ARE DOING THIS EVERY NIGHT.
AND SWEET THE QUESTIONS, AND
NICOLE SAPHIER AND DR. MARTY
KERRY, THANK YOU FOR BEING UP
WITH US EARLY IS THE CASE,
DEPENDING ON YOUR TIME ZONE.
GOOD TO HAVE YOU WITH US
ALL RIGHT, I WILL START WITH THE
FIRST QUESTION, AND A FEW
QUESTIONS THAT HAVE BEEN ASKED
AND ANSWERED.
NUMBER ONE WHAT IS THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN COVID-19 AND
FLUKE.
SINCE BOTH VIRAL WHY IS COVID-19
MORE DANGEROUS THAN FLU SINCE
THE FLU HAS KILLED MORE PEOPLE
THAN COVID-19?
DR. COMMIT AT LEAST AT THIS
POINT.
>> WHAT IS CONCERNING ABOUT
COVID-19, THAT IS A SISTER OF A
CORONAVIRUS WHICH CAUSES THE
COMMON COLD.
IT WAS INVOLVED WITH SARS.
AND A SEPARATE VIRUS.
THIS HAS A RAPID INCREASE.
THAT IS WHAT WE ARE CONCERNED
ABOUT.
IT IS GREAT TO SPREAD AND WE ARE
SEEING IN ITALY, THESE CASES
COME IN AT 90 DEATHS, TEN DAYS
AGO IN ONE DATE TO 350 DEATHS ON
SATURDAY.
THAT IS WHAT WE ARE CONCERNED
ABOUT WITH COVID-19.
>> Shannon: DOCTOR, ANYTHING
YOU WANT TO ADD ABOUT THE
DIFFERENCES?
>> A LOT OF THE PANIC COMES FROM
THE UNKNOWN.
WITH THE FLU COMMIT IS SOMETHING
SOMETHING THAT COMES EVERY YEAR,
AND WE HAVE VACCINES FOR IT.
WE HAVE DONE TREATMENTS FOR IT
AND TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
AMERICANS DIE EVERY YEAR, IT
JUST COME TO EXPECT IT.
AND REALLY, WE ARE ABLE TO
PREVENT A LOT OF THE ILLNESS.
WHAT THE CONCERN WITH COVID-19,
A RAMPING UP OF CASES AND MORE
AND MORE CASES EVERY DAY, BY THE
HOUR.
IT’S NOT WHETHER THE HEALTH
SYSTEM CAN ACCEPT THAT ALL RAPID
AT ONE SPIRITS ONE DOCTOR, THE
NEXT QUESTION FROM PETER SNUG.
WHAT IS BEING TAKEN A NUMBER OF
BEDS TO CARE FOR THOSE WHO NEED
TO BE HOSPITALIZED.
WHAT ARE THE LIMITING FACTORS TO
INCREASING THAT NUMBER AS SOON
AS POSSIBLE?
>> THESE ARE MILLION-DOLLAR
QUESTIONS RIGHT NOW.
SOMETHING WE ARE LOOKING AT
CLOSELY.
UNFORTUNATELY, THERE HAVE BEEN
MOVEMENTS FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT IN TERMS OF TRYING TO
GET FUNDING.
WE HAVE THE BILL ALTHOUGH NOT
PASSED IN THE SENATE, PASSED
CONGRESS AS WELL AS DECLARING A
NATIONAL EMERGENCY ACT AND THE
STAFFORD ACTS.
WE ARE GETTING FUNDING SO WE ARE
ABLE TO MOBILIZE SUPPORT.
THERE ARE A LOT OF HOSPITALS
RIGHT NOW SAYING WE WILL CANCEL
ALL ELECTRIC PROCEDURES THAT WAY
TO KEEP BEDS FREE AND
HEALTH CARE STAFF AVAILABLE.
WE ALSO HAVE MAKESHIFT MEDICAL
CLINICS BEING SET UP.
SOME BY THE GOVERNMENT AND SOME
BEING SET UP BY PRIVATE
INSTITUTIONS.
A LOT OF HEALTH CARE HOSPITALS
AND SMALL PRACTICES ARE DOING
TELEMEDICINE.
THAT IS TO KEEP PATIENTS OUT OF
THE HOSPITAL.
ALL OF THESE THINGS TOGETHER
TRYING TO MAKE SURE THE HOSPITAL
CAN TAKE MORE PATIENTS.
WE ARE STILL IN THE MIDDLE OF
FLU SEASON SO THAT HOSPITALS CAN
BE QUITE FULL.
SO THE GOAL IS TO KEEP THE
NUMBERS DOWN AS MUCH AS
POSSIBLE.
>> Shannon: DR. McGARRY I
WAS READING HOW THE MILITARY CAN
GET INVOLVED AND ONE OF THE
THINGS I WAS READING ABOUT, THE
HOSPITALS OF A CERTAIN AGE
WHO WOULD REMEMBER THIS SHOW, SO
WILDLY POPULAR WITH THE ABILITY
TO ADD TO THE BEDS IN THE
SYSTEMS BY STANDING UP FOR THEIR
FACILITIES IN EMERGENCIES AS
WELL.
IS THAT PART OF THIS EQUATION TO
MAKE SURE WE HAVE ENOUGH BEDS?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
THE MILITARY HAS ITS OWN MEDICAL
YOUR SYSTEM AND ON THE
BATTLEFIELD IN SET UP OPERATING
SYSTEMS.
WOO HAND HAS 19 HOSPITALS AND
STILL OVER RUN.
THIS IS A CITY OF 10 MILLION
PEOPLE.
IT’S NOT THE ENTIRE POPULATION
OF CHINA.
SO WE NEED TO DO THAT.
WE NEED TO EXPAND AND WE WILL
NOT BE ABLE TO DO IT FAST
ENOUGH.
THAT IS WHY WE TALK ABOUT REDUCE
TRANSMISSION RATES SO WE DON’T
GET THAT SURGE AT ONCE.
IT’S A DOUBLE WHAMMY.
HEALTH CARE WORKERS AT HIGHEST
RISK AND CAN BE OUT OF
COMMISSION.
AND A MASSIVE INFLUX WHICH
REQUIRES MORE HEALTH WORKERS.
>> Shannon: WE HAVE BEEN
LOOKING AT THE STORY TELEGRAPH
TODAY TALKING ABOUT THE PROTOCOL
DOCUMENT THEY SAY THEY HAVE SEEN
IN ITALY WHERE THEY ARE MAKING
DECISIONS HOW THEY WILL DECIDE
WHO GETS PACIFIC MEDICAL CARE.
THEY ARE TALKING ABOUT PEOPLE
OVER 80 AND HAVE POOR HEALTH IN
A SCORING SYSTEM FOR MAKING
THESE DECISIONS.
SO THAT LEADS TO MY NEXT
QUESTION.
IT COMES IN, ONCE THE SYSTEM
BECOMES OVERLOADED, WHAT
CRITERIA WILL BE APPLIED TO
TREE -- TO TREAT PATIENCE?
AS A MEDICAL -- THAT IS A
DECISION I ASSUME YOU DON’T WANT
TO MAKE?
>> FIRST OF ALL IF YOU NEED
ANYTHING DONE IN A HOSPITAL THAT
CAN WAIT, WAIT.
IF IT WILL NOT INCREASE ANY
RISK, HOSPITALS ARE OFTEN NOW
ASKING YOU TO JUST PUT THINGS
OFF, OKAY?
NO COSMETIC SURGERY FOR THE NEXT
THREE OR FOUR MONTHS.
WE NEED TO BUILD CAPACITY.
THE WAY WE ARE GOING TO DO THAT
IS FIGURE OUT WHO NEEDS
INTENSIVE CARE, WHO NEEDS A
RESPIRATOR, WHO IS CLOSE TO
NEEDING A RESPIRATOR.
THOSE ARE THE PEOPLE WE WILL
FOCUS ON.
MOST OF THESE CASES ARE MILD OR
HAVE NO SYMPTOMS.
THOSE PATIENTS SHOULD NOT SHOW
UP SHOW UP.
>> Shannon: DOCTOR, THIS TWEET
FROM TRACY.
WHAT IS THE LENGTH OF THE
ILLNESS?
IS IT 14 DAYS, LONGER?
WE HEARD ABOUT THESE PEOPLE WHO
SAID THEY NEVER HAD BAD SYMPTOMS
BUT SOME ARE QUARANTINED FROM
THE CRUISE SHIPS AND THEY KEEP
TESTING POSITIVE.
THEY ARE NOT COUGHING.
THEY ARE HITTING 40 DAYS NOW.
SO WHAT SHOULD YOU EXPECT WITH
BEING SICK?
>> SHANNON, THAT IS A GREAT
QUESTION AND ALSO IT KEEPS
CHANGING AS DATA COMES OUT.
THE INCUBATION PERIOD IS ABOUT
FIVE DAYS WHEN EXPOSED TO THE
VIRUS WITH THE SYMPTOMS.
WHICH IS DIFFERENT THAN THE FLU
BECAUSE IT IS SHORTER WITH THE
FLU, THEREFORE, YOU GET SICK OR
SOONER AND ISOLATING YOURSELF
SOONER.
WHICH IS WHY WITH COVID-19, WE
TEND TO BE INFECTING MORE PEOPLE
BECAUSE IT WILL DRAMATIC WITH
MILD SYMPTOMS LONGER.
IN THE SYMPTOMS, AT THAT POINT,
IT SEEMS LIKE THE SYMPTOMS STICK
AROUND MUCH LONGER AS WELL
UNLIKE THE FLU.
THE FLU ONLY TAKES A COUPLE OF
DAYS.
YOU FEEL CRUMMY WITH A DAYS BUT
IT GOES AWAY IN A FEW DAYS.
BUT WITH COVID-19, PEOPLE HAVE
SYMPTOMS A LOT
SYMPTOMS A LOT LONGER, UP TO 14
DAYS.
PEOPLE ARE TESTING AND STILL
TESTING POSITIVE LONGER THAN
THAT.
ACTUALLY, POTENTIALLY THEY ARE
SHEDDING THE VIRUS BUT IT DOES
NOT NECESSARILY MEAN
ACTIVELY CONTAGIOUS.
WE ARE STILL TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT EXACTLY WHAT ALL THIS MEANS.
SOME PEOPLE SHED LONGER THAN
OTHERS.
IT IS HARD TO SAY.
ONCE YOU ACTUALLY GET SYMPTOMS,
MANDATORY 14 DAY QUARANTINE
UNTIL YOU HAVE AT LEAST TWO
NEGATIVE TEST 24 HOURS.
>> Shannon: OKAY, THIS IS A
QUESTION WE HAVE GOTTEN A LOT.
THIS COMES TO US FROM -- WHAT IS
THE CURRENT CONSENSUS OR DATA
HOW LONG IT CAN LAST ON
SURFACES?
A WIDE DISPARITY ANYWHERE FROM
THREE HOURS TO 28 DAYS.
WE NEED CLARIFICATION ON THIS,
DOCTOR.
>> IT IS TWO HOURS ON COPPER
HORSE FIELD.
IT COULD BE LONGER BUT ON
FABRICS OR PLASTIC, IT COULDE
DAYS.
SO PEOPLE NEED TO BE MINDFUL
THAT SURFACES ARE ONE OF THE
MOST COMMON MODES OF
TRANSMISSION, ESPECIALLY OUR
PHONES.
WHEN YOU WASH YOUR HANDS, YOU’VE
GOT TO REMEMBER THAT PHONE IS AN
EXTENSION OF YOUR HANDS.
>> Shannon: IT IS TRUE.
WE SET THOSE THINGS DOWN
EVERYWHERE.
>> WHAT IS IMPORTANT TO POINT
OUT, LAST WEEK A STUDY CAME OUT
THAT TESTED AND ESSENTIALLY A
VIRUS.
AND THEN THEY RECORDED WHETHER
OR NOT THEY COULD STILL IDENTIFY
PARTICLES THERE.
THE PARTICLES WERE ON STEEL AND
PLASTIC FOR THREE DAYS AND
CARDBOARD BOX, ONE DAY,
LINGERING IN THE AIR FOR THREE
HOURS AFTER.
IT IS IMPORTANT TO REMEMBER,
THAT IS JUST A STUDY THAT IS NOT
ACTUALLY REAL LIFE.
JUST BECAUSE THEY CAN STILL FIND
THE PARTICLES THERE DOES NOT
NECESSARILY THEY ARE VIABLE TO
CAUSE INFECTION.
THE BOTTOM LINE IS, THE MOST
COMMON WAKE YOU WERE GOING TO
GET THIS IS BECAUSE YOU ARE NEAR
ASYMPTOMATIC COUGHING AND
SNEEZING.
SO AS THE DOCTOR SAID, WHAT YOU
WANT TO DO ESPECIALLY RIGHT NOW,
WE ARE SOCIALLY DISTANCING.
YOU SEE WE ARE IN OUR HOME
STUDIOS.
AND WASH YOUR HANDS CONSTANTLY.